hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast i'm your host sean carroll
for those of you who are physics fans
out there you will know that one of the
very long-standing
big picture puzzles in physics is
quantum gravity reconciling einstein's
general theory of relativity
which is a theory of gravity with the
fundamental principles of quantum
mechanics
and a problem with this puzzle is that
we don't have a lot of experimental
guidance in fact the only experimental
guidance we have
is that classical general relativity
seems to work very well
and quantum mechanics seems to work very
well so they're somehow going to be
reconciled someday
something we do have though are thought
experiments
which can help guide us in thinking
about well
if we do eventually manage to quantize
gravity
what will it look like what shape will
it have what
will it teach us what will be the
fundamental ingredients and the most
important thought experiment we have
is the black hole information loss
puzzle
this is something that was given to us
by stephen hawking who in the 1970s
showed
that black holes aren't completely black
when you include quantum mechanics
they radiate and eventually they'll
evaporate completely away
into essentially information free
thermal radiation the puzzle is
that most of physics doesn't work like
that most of physics
conserves information even if you throw
a book into a bonfire
the information in the book is somehow
we think encoded in all the heat and
light
that is made in the process of burning
the book whereas if hawking were right
then black holes are different they
destroy the information that gets thrown
into them
a lot of us don't believe that's
actually the right answer we believe
that the
calculation that hawking did has been
incomplete
but it's very very hard as it turns out
to figure out mechanisms that can
somehow get the information
out so the hope is that by looking for
such mechanisms
we can learn something about quantum
gravity even if we don't have
direct experimental evidence for it and
interestingly there has been
progress over the years in just the past
year or two
there's been what looks like very
exciting progress
in this quest to understand how the
information gets out
of evaporating black holes so today's
guest is neda engelhardt who is a
professor of physics at
mit she's one of the people who has been
involved in this research which seems
so promising and she's also really
really good at bringing some abstract
ideas down to earth
that's important here because i will
tell you right ahead of time
uh this is a brain stretching exercise
this podcast episode
we're gonna go pretty deep we're gonna
start very gently you know it's
supposed to be understandable to
everybody throughout the entire
conversation
but we're gonna get into not only black
hole evaporation and things like that
but the ads cft correspondence wormholes
and the structure of quantum gravity
entanglement all that good stuff it's
all going to appear here
i think it all does make sense i think
it is not yet fully
formed one of the things that neda
mentions is that we don't yet claim to
have the final answer
what we claim is to have some very
interesting
tidbits of information that might help
us get to the final answer of how to
quantize gravity i think that makes this
both an enjoyable and maybe even an
important episode of mindscape
let me take this opportunity to give you
the occasional reminder that we have a
patreon account for mindscape if you
want to support us
financially i say yes it's just me you
know it's just me
so you can go to patreon.com sean m
carroll
if you want to give uh support at some
level of support per episode
and most of the benefit of doing this is
that you feel good that you're
supporting something that you like
but also you get some more tangible
benefits in the form of you get to ask
questions at the monthly ask me anything
episodes
and also you get an ad free version of
the podcast if that's important to you
so
we appreciate the support we appreciate
all the listeners whether you support us
or not we think it's a great community
to have here
the mindscape listeners uh i personally
sean
thank you for coming along with me on
this journey in so many different topics
that we cover i know
we like the physics ones we like all the
other ones as well
i've been learning a lot i really love
doing this podcast this is a fun thing
thanks for sticking around and let's go
[Music]
nettle engelhardt welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you very much we
have
ahead of us today an ambitious show
by the standards of the podcast we're
gonna try to not only discuss some of
the
difficult ideas in theoretical physics
but like very cutting edge ones like
we're talking about stuff that
has literally been going on in the past
year
among some of the highest reaches of
theoretical physics and correct me if
i'm wrong but my impression is
the dust hasn't settled yet right i mean
this is an area where we're still
in the midst of working things out so we
shouldn't expect the final answers to
emerge over the next hour or so
absolutely i would be amazed if we had
final answers over the next hour
okay so so you don't have them already
and we're not we won't be mentioning
them but yeah who knows a good idea
could happen that that's been
that's been known to occur but why don't
we we have to start somewhere
we can't explain general relativity in
black holes in full generality so let's
imagine that the audience has heard of
black holes
they've heard that gravity is the
curvature of space time they've even
heard
that stephen hawking showed in the 1970s
that black holes
give off radiation that they have a
temperature they're not completely black
um something that they may have heard
but let's try to explain
is the idea that the as wonderful uh
proposal as it was this discovery of
hawkings that black holes will
eventually evaporate
leads to puzzles leads to problems the
information loss
problem so uh as well as you can like
what's the big problem why is it an
issue that black holes evaporate away
yeah so that was a a lovely introduction
of the current status
so we we have this prediction by uh by
stephen hawking that black holes
evaporate
and if you uh if you take that
prediction
very seriously and you follow the
calculations
you find that what we call what we call
information
is loss and this is in fact in
contradiction with some of
the basic laws of quantum mechanics
which we expect information to always be
conserved
and what we what we mean by information
here is very analogous to
what you might imagine are bits uncoded
in a computer
just a quantum version and we call them
qubits
and the idea is that there's some
information about these qubits that
that simply disappears from the universe
altogether
when the black hole evaporates now
things can go into a black hole
and they might not be accessible to us
living outside of the black hole but as
long as they still exist somewhere in
the universe we say that
the information in the universe has not
been destroyed but if the black hole has
taken some
information with it and then disappeared
altogether then that information is gone
from the universe
and we really have a process in the
universe that loses information
and this is catastrophic from a couple
of different perspectives
one of which you can think about in the
following physics is
what we call a predictive science you
give us some
information about what is happening now
and we will tell you oh this thing will
happen
in the future we're not fortune dollars
of course but the idea is if some
particle is behaving in some way now
if we know its properties now we can
predict what its behavior will be in the
future
and this also works in the other
direction if you are telling us how
things are now
then we should be able to tell you how
things were
some time ago but the problem is that if
information is lost that means that
after the black hole has evaporated
it is impossible for us to reverse
engineer what was happening
some time ago and so physics is no
longer
postdictive as we call it able to
predict or post the past
which is uh which is truly catastrophic
because it means that
this is a there's a fundamental weakness
in physics which is something that we
have not ever seen and have not been
able to incorporate into our theories
i mean i guess i'm going to be a little
bit of a devil's advocate here so i'm
not revealing my own
sympathies which i think are exactly the
same as yours but it's my job to play
uh to give voice to the skeptics uh you
know when we invented quantum mechanics
in the 1920s we
we did away with the with the very
precious idea that you could make exact
deterministic predictions about future
experiments
maybe we should give up on the idea that
post-diction is possible and
physics is information conserving and no
no less a person than stephen hawking
actually believed that that was probably
the right answer for at least a little
while
definitely but we did not give up
determinism with quantum mechanics it's
very
important distinction that even though
we
we gave up the the idea that something
might have a definite state say in the
schroedinger cat
experiment that the cat is either alive
or dead before we've measured it
we we may have given up on on that but
we have not given up on determinism in
the sense that
a given quantum state evolves into some
other quantum state by a process which
we can describe
and so i would say the determinism is is
a unifying
feature of everything that that we have
seen and all the theories that we've
constructed to date
now it's possible and indeed stephen
hawking subscribed to this for a long
time
that uh information is in fact lost but
then we have to ask ourselves how how
how is quantum gravity
a what kind of quantum theory is quantum
gravity that it loses information
quantum gravity being the descriptor of
the
quantum mechanics and general relativity
together if it loses information
what do we have to modify about quantum
mechanics so that this actually
is a consistent theory well um this bit
about determinism i want to clarify a
little bit
because um if we believe that the only
thing that ever happened in the universe
was
the evolution according to the
schrodinger equation the the fundamental
equation of quantum mechanics then i
agree it's completely deterministic
and my good friend hugh everett who
invented the many worlds interpretation
thought that that was right but
there are other approaches to quantum
mechanics where it's truly not
deterministic
this is true um so so again there are
people who subscribe to information loss
and
uh there is no there's currently no
empirical
experiment that we can conduct to
determine
which one is correct information
conservation or information loss
although certainly the recent
developments point us in one direction
rather than the other
i would say that many of us find
information conservation
much more palatable because it is
something that allows us to keep the
tenants
uh the principles of quantum mechanics
intact
yeah i mean i think i think that's
exactly right and but i do want to i
mean something that's always bugged me
this
i'm just going to be the guinea pig for
all the things that have bugged me about
the information
paradox for 20 or 30 years now
um the time when quantum mechanics
does not look deterministic is when we
make a measurement
and we can argue whether or not really
it is deterministic we just don't see it
because there are other branches of the
wave function or whether like
you know someone like penrose would say
that there is a true collapse of the
wave function
uh at that moment um but if
the way that we teach quantum mechanics
in textbooks
says that information is lost when we
make a quantum measurement
uh isn't how why are we so upset when
information seems to be
being lost when black holes give off uh
radiation i mean
until we observe it we wouldn't know and
when we observe it we collapse the wave
function and it looks like information's
lost anyway
yeah so let me maybe make an analogous
picture of what you're describing
suppose that i
am an experimentalist working with some
tabletop experiment
and i have a some quantum particles um
and some maybe some of my particles are
escaped away from my tabletop
and i've lost information it's very
analogous in the sense that
there's some interference the edge of
the table perhaps that has caused
information loss
the difference is that my table is not
the entire universe
and it is a subsystem of the universe
and the
information loss is is reasonable when
you're looking at a subsystem a subset
a wave function that describes some part
of the universe rather than all of it
but it's more troubling when you're
literally describing everything in the
known universe
and or everything in the universe and
nonetheless information is lost it
raises the question of where does it go
right and in fact as i indicated i'm
completely
sympathetic to this point of view i mean
you're just just to be clear because i
think that
listening to me on this podcast has
maybe
poisoned the mind of a lot of listeners
like most working physicists
don't worry that much about the
foundations of quantum mechanics uh
do you think of yourself as a many
worlds person or uh
i don't really care about that much
let's think about black holes kind of
person or what
i would say i sometimes i i worry but
most of the time i don't worry
yeah most of the time i fall into the
latter category
right i mean the the thing you just said
about the universe should conserve
information
certainly is uh uh everett sympathetic
or something like that but maybe it's
not exactly the same thing
okay anyway uh good i've gotten some of
my itches scratched there that was very
helpful
um so but let's just be clear on
why it's a problem so we have a black
hole it's evaporating
um it seems clear why information
would be lost in the sense that if i
throw a book into the black hole
uh i can't get it back but now the black
hole completely evaporates away
what's to say that the information that
was in the black hole
isn't somehow subtly encoded in the
radiation that comes out
well that is the the hope uh the hope is
that
somehow there is information which is
encoded
that the hawking radiation actually
encodes this information
now the calculation that that hawking
did
does not support this conclusion and so
you're left with
two possibilities either you have to say
where hawking went wrong
what he failed to take into account and
where the calculation must be corrected
or you are forced to conclude that
information is in fact lost
and this is why we call it the
information paradox because information
loss
is very problematic for the reasons we
just described
although again some people do subscribe
to it and on the other hand you have a
calculation which appears to be correct
and we don't a priori immediately know
what is wrong with it
right and so that's why yeah that's why
it's different than just
throwing the book into a bonfire for
example precisely yeah that's exactly
the difference
somehow that information in the book
it's kind of weird i think that maybe a
lot of people
don't quite get how natural this is to
physicists but
we we would say that literally all the
information about where the ink marks
were on the
letters in the book somehow affects the
light and heat and ash that comes out of
the fire
and that doesn't seem to be what happens
in black holes exactly i mean if you
think about it suppose you had a really
a really great computer that could
simulate exactly
how the bonfire works and it was able to
miraculously somehow to
track every single molecule for the
whole process every atom every particle
then you would be able at the end of the
day to say okay well the information
about the book was somehow
encoded in everything that came out of
the fire but
black holes appear to be different right
and
there's a lot of places we can sort of
go to fill in this picture a little bit
maybe you'd be useful to talk about the
entropy of black holes because this is
part of what hawking invented right not
just that they give off radiation but
that means we can associate an entropy
with it
right right so yeah so there was uh the
history of this roughly speaking
is a of a personal favorite starting
point
which is that um the there is this idea
in general relativity
that black holes don't uh that they're
completely described by
um by certain simple quantities that you
can measure like their mass
and and what this means is that there is
no uncertainty
about the about the black hole if you
know say its mass or how fast is
rotating
and uh and there being no uncertainty in
a mathematical way
means that it has no entropy so one of
my favorite stories
is about about jacob beckenstein and and
his advisor
wheeler who gave him a problem to think
about which was if you take a cup of hot
tea
that obviously has entropy and you throw
it into a black hole
how could did you manage to decrease the
entropy of the universe and if so
is this a violation of the second law of
thermodynamics which states that entropy
must always go up
and i at the time jacob beckenstein was
a graduate student
so he thought very long and hard about
this and eventually he
suggested that actually it must be the
case that black holes have entropy
and even though general relativity
doesn't seem to think so that entropy
must be a result of some deep quantum
gravity
mechanism uh and i suppose it's a
favorite for me because i think of all
of the
problems i could give to my graduate
students without being considered too
hard of an advisor
well wheeler he must have been doing
something right right his students
turned out pretty good
yeah it's true it's true i'd be i'd be
happy to emulate
richard feynman hugh everett kip thorne
jacob beckenstein yeah he did okay
but it hated okay yeah i mean maybe we
should
i think that everyone who's listening or
at least 90 of people who are listening
here
have heard the word entropy and think
they know what it means but i bet
that over the next few minutes uh we're
gonna have to be nitpicky about what is
meant
by entropy do you have a favorite
definition in this context
uh i'd like to well i have some favorite
mathematical definitions but intuitive
the intuitive definition that i might
give is that
i would like to think of entropy as a
measure of ignorance
of of some system so i might know
something about the system for example
your hot cup of tea i might know its
temperature i might know its volume
but i don't necessarily know the
location of every molecule at every
moment
right and i would like to think of
entropy my one of my favorite ways of
thinking about entropy as the ignorance
of where those molecules are what
they're doing at any given moment
so ignorance about some some aspect of
the system you're interested in
given that you might know some other
things you might know some larger
quantities or even some smaller
quantities
yeah and i love that way of thinking
about in this context because it it
brings us
right to the beginnings of sort of a
tension
between the the general relativity way
of thinking and the
the let's say the microscopic way of
thinking because just like you said a
black hole has no hair right black holes
are the same
if you know what their mass charge and
spin are so there's no way
it classically should have entropy
because there's no
information being lost and so you could
see why wheeler
would be worried um but so and so i
guess that
the lesson is classical general
relativity
can't be the right answer if black holes
evaporate like if black holes didn't
evaporate it would be fine right you
would just say well that
that cup of coffee left the universe
it's inside the black hole and the black
hole will be there forever
right as long as you're willing to
accept that the black hole has entropy
which is uh well either that or you're
willing to give up on the second law of
thermodynamics well i guess you could
say
i'm just making this up as i go along i
mean maybe you could say something like
if we have a black hole the region
outside the black hole of our universe
is an open system
right it can it can throw things away
and therefore maybe there's no
reason to be too persnickety about the
second law that's right we can certainly
think of it that way
we can also we don't immediately run
into any problems if we just postulate
that black holes do have entropy
and it's not we don't we can accept that
and uh without thinking about black hole
evaporation
in a priori right but it was uh
hawking's
annoyance with beckenstein that led us
to the invention of
black hole radiation that's right i
think in fact i think if i if memory
serves i believe that hawking in fact
set out to
show that black holes do not actually
have a temperature and therefore this
entropy analogy is purely an analogy i
believe that's the story i've been told
and uh and what he ended up showing was
actually quite the opposite that
they literally are thermal objects with
a temperature
and an entropy yeah i think that's
literally the story that hawking
said in a brief history of time so it's
not like someone is attributing
this to him but if you're a lifelong
learner as i suspect many mindscape
listeners are
you're going to love the great courses
plus the great courses has an enormous
library of courses
for everyone from high school age on up
taught by some of the world's best
professors and teachers
in a wide variety of topics from
astrophysics and music to human
psychology
and the great courses plus is a
streaming service that gives you
access to these courses in an incredibly
convenient format
you can get it on the great courses plus
apps you can watch on your mobile device
or you could see it on your computer or
your tv you could sit at home with your
family and learn together
for something of a change of pace let me
recommend a course by mark
leary who is a psychology professor and
the course is called your public persona
self-presentation in everyday life it
will teach you the tactics we use
to manage other people's impressions and
how to achieve our goals
so right now there's a special offer for
mindscape listeners
sign up for the great courses plus and
get a free month of access to the entire
library
go to this special url the great courses
plus dot com slash mindscape
that's t-h-e great courses p-l-u-s
dot com slash mindscape
i mean so maybe it's not surprising
maybe it is but when hawking
allows for there to be quantum effects
near the black hole
they evaporate and now
the universe is a closed system again
because the black hole disappears and
now the entropy had to go somewhere if
you believe in the second law
that's right and yeah and i suppose the
crux of the matter
is that if we think of entropy as
measuring ignorance then all of a sudden
you're ignorant about something
even though you know everything about
the entire universe
as the black hole has evaporated that's
that's the puzzle or a puzzle at least
okay so what what is the reason why
people just didn't quantize gravity and
solve everything straight away
uh well you know we would if we could
that at the end of the day a uh well
let me let me let me say this in this
way um
for a very long time we thought that the
only way
to resolve really any aspect of the
black hole information paradox
is to actually have a full
theory of quantum gravity that we
understood from first principles
and um and one that we could use to
describe the black hole evaporation
process
and i suppose i'm jumping a little bit
ahead but one of the
one of the aspects that of the recent
developments over the past
year and a half or so that have been so
miraculous is that we
actually have not needed that kind of
access to the this deep mysterious
regime
of quantum gravity in order to be able
to make tremendous progress
on the black hole information paradox
and that's what's been causing so much
excitement and ripples and uh
in the field of the black hole
information problem yeah i mean in some
sense
since we don't need data about quantum
gravity for the past
i don't know 50 years 50 years um people
have been 4
20 45 years uh people been using the
black hole information laws
uh problem as the thing that we need to
keep in mind when we try to quantize
gravity is that a fair way to say it
yeah i i i would that's one way to say
it some people have certainly attempted
to tackle it
head on in in several different ways but
i would say
it was i would describe progress on the
black hole information paradox as
something that comes in uh
in waves usually there's we're silent on
it because it's something that yeah we
just kind of need to keep in mind when
we quantize gravity and when we think
about quantum gravity something that
needs to be resolved
and then all of a sudden someone will
have some insight and uh
and that'll that'll result in some
frantic activity for a short amount of
time as everyone thinks that
maybe this is the time that we solve the
paradox
and uh and it sort of dies out for a
while until it gets survived by some new
insight
i think one of the really exciting
things that have been happening the past
year and a half is that
there have been a lot of a lot of
progress
not just reformulating the paradox in
different ways but actually
progress towards resolving it and it
doesn't appear to be slowing down as far
as i can tell
not yet that's good we've caught you at
the right time um despite pandemics and
things like that we're still making
progress in theoretical physics
it's good to know um but okay so
but i like this idea that um we're not
claiming to get a full
quantum theory of gravity but what we're
doing is using
what we think we know about black holes
to tease out
properties that that theory should have
and if
black holes are going to have entropy
which is what hawking uh
said then it must be the case that black
holes are not all the same right or that
there's many many many different things
that could be going on
inside the black hole just as a cup of
coffee could have many many different
arrangements of its molecule
absolutely yeah we have and just
standing outside the black hole
we all we know is what we're ignorant of
we know essentially how much information
they might be ignorant of but we
don't actually know what that
information is i mean do we have good
ideas do you have a favorite idea for
what the
as we what we call the micro states of
the black hole
are is it like little pixels of quantum
space time or something more subtle
uh i think that i i i'm sufficiently
confused
at this about this point that i think
that in certain cases
there have been people have actually
been able to count microstates
and i think in those cases it's uh it's
fairly incontrovertible as long as you
agree with the counting method and the
theory or framework that they used
but the what what exactly they're
looking at or
although sometimes it's very indirect um
but
i think in in general dynamical black
holes meaning black holes that change
with time
i i don't know i don't know the answer
to that and i think it's something that
we are going to have to solve sooner or
later yeah i mean i like to leave these
open
i like to mention these open problems
out here and hope that some young person
listening to the podcast will grow up to
to solve them and then you know mention
mindscape in their nobel prize
acceptance speeches
inspiring their interest in them if
you're listening uh if you're listening
and you have a solution to the
microstate problem you should definitely
write it up into a paper exactly
okay so we so this is the the i i think
this is
pretty good in terms of laying out the
problem we have these black holes
classically they all look the same
the story about evaporation and entropy
seems to imply that actually there's a
lot of different micro states that look
the same but we don't know what they are
maybe if we knew what they are and how
they relate to the outside world they
would explain
how the information can get out but that
but is that a fair way of saying what
the
what the aspiration is that somehow the
process of evaporation
preserves the information and puts it
into the outgoing radiation
that would be what the what we would
want to see
we would want to see an explicit precise
mechanism
by which the information that went into
the black hole
information about the microstates of the
black hole is encoded
in the radiation that escapes it that
would be
that's sort of the uh the pinnacle of
what we're working towards
and part of the problem is just that if
i do throw a prop a book into the black
hole and i sort of
trace what happens to it it you know it
goes deep into the center and hits a
singularity so just physically it seems
to be far away
from the horizon where the radiation is
coming from yes that's exactly right so
there's
there's a problem where it seems how can
the there has to be some kind of a
it would appear to have to be some kind
of a process that doesn't respect
causality
in order for information that went into
the black hole
to end up in the radiation and um and
and
so in particular we say that the event
horizon we say is a point from which
nothing can return
uh what that essentially means is that
nothing can escape
from from inside the black hole to
outside of the black hole but clearly
what we're saying here is that
somehow quantum gravity manages to still
place the information
from inside the black hole to outside of
it even though
that would violate our notions of
causality right
and this is again maybe some place where
it's going to be useful to be
careful and persnickety because again
quantum mechanics
gives us a kind of non-locality right
there is
this thing called entanglement and it
bothered einstein because it was a
spooky action at a distance so maybe we
should
explain what entanglement is and why
that's not just by itself enough to
explain how information can come out
yes so entanglement i suppose my
favorite
um entanglement is is very much a
quantum phenomenon
so it's uh it's one which is which is
difficult to explain via analogy
because to be completely honest there
isn't really an analogy
right not a good one there are plenty
bad ones yeah there's there's no analogy
that perfectly captures the
the meaning of of entanglement but um
i i generally like to to think of it as
some kind of a correlation between
between two objects that are separated
from one another
so um you might you might imagine that
you have a a couple of coins for example
and there was some mysterious law of
nature that essentially tells you that
whether you get heads or tails on one of
your coins
is it it's related to whether it's
headset tails
in the on the other coin even though the
two coins are very far separated from
one another
this kind of correlation between two
objects that
are not able to communicate with one
another is uh it's this type of
non-locality
that appears in quantum mechanics and i
don't know sean if you have any
any other analogies that you that you
like to use
that maybe make this somewhat more
conceptual
but it is true that quantum mechanics
does have in some sense a built-in in
locality a non-locality
in this uh in the sense of this
entanglement across space
no actually i completely agree with your
impression that the analogies fail and
therefore i basically don't use them i
say
imagine there are some spins and they're
going to be up and down and you can
measure them and
it's exactly what you said the spin is
going to be spin up or spin down
uh as analogous to the coin being heads
or tails the extra little bit
of course is that with the coins you
have the idea that
it is heads or tails we just don't know
which right whereas with true quantum
systems it's in a superposition
and it can be in a superposition of both
we don't know which
whether the spin is going to be up or
down but we know if it's one then the
other one's going to be the other way
and that's that's the weird non-locality
right right the the is there's an issue
where yeah a classical coin naturally
has is either heads or
tails whereas a quantum coin is
simultaneously some percentage heads and
some percentage tails
and if that's uh if that's not
counterintuitive enough
yeah exactly come up with other things
well but and this is also where
you know it's interesting because i move
back and forth between the sort of
theoretical physics gravity communities
and also the foundation the physics
community
and they make a big deal about
non-locality but it's always in this
sort of bell's theorem entanglement
quantum sent
and the you know particle physicists and
gravity people
say well it's really hard to explain how
information comes out of black holes
because you need some non-local
transmission of information somehow and
it's maybe it's worth explaining why
that's a different kind of non-locality
right like we know that there's a kind
of non-locality in quantum mechanics but
that's not enough it's not what you mean
by the kind of non-local you need to get
the information out of a book that's
falling into the singularity
right it's the i would say the crux of
the matter is that
there is a theorem in quantum
information which tells you that you
cannot
use entanglement alone to send
information to transmit
information so it is not possible to
send information without actually having
it have having it traversed at least no
faster than the speed of light
between two objects even if there is
entanglement between the two
so entanglement is not enough on its own
to send information
you have to supplement it with what is
known as classical communication
which is to say something that does not
travel faster than light
it is not enough on its own and that
really bugs physicists right like so
is it is it safe to say that even before
getting to
your favorite or or the field's new
favorite ways of
getting the information out um just
setting up the problem if you think that
information does get out you're going to
need
some kind of location non-locality
non-local transmission of information
and that's not what we would expect from
our experience with ordinary quantum
mechanics or quantum field theory
exactly yeah that's uh that's what
that's that is what is bugging us in the
sense
that there is a we know that you cannot
use entanglement on its own
to to just communicate this information
we know that you can't do that
and at the same time we have to be able
to use something that
has to be some way for the information
to uh to still get out
even though there is no let me put it
this way um
there is no way for anything that
travels
no faster than light to actually send
the information out right right but you
know okay so
so in order so an ordinary quantum field
theory
which we think is the best way we have
of describing all the experiments we've
ever done
uh really has locality built into its
bones but apparently gravity is
different somehow
and i bet that a lot of the listeners
have heard this idea that there's
something called the holographic
principle that the world is really only
two-dimensional and we're just a
projection of it so that came out of
thinking about the black hole
information problem right
uh the idea of holography or
are you referring to ads cft uh let's
start with the idea of holography and
then
uh it gets sort of in your face at the
80s cft example
right yeah so this idea of the black
hole as the
the black hole event horizon sentence is
a hologram
um which yeah the idea being that
somehow even though it seems very
strange all
of the information about gravity in some
part of the space time is encoded on the
boundary of it
so you might think okay i'm sitting in a
room and
somehow if someone were just to look at
all of the walls of the room
they would be able to completely
describe everything that i am
doing in the room right now everything
all the objects that are sitting in the
room
and that is a very it's a very strange
idea but
uh but it's one that was born out of
thinking about black holes
because the entropy of a black hole for
example
is something that you can compute
knowing only
only by measuring only quantities that
are
on its boundary on the event horizon so
there is uh
there is a clear analogy there to the
room and the boundary of the room
and in some sense this is how the ideas
about the
the hologram and the gravitational
hologram came about
and exactly and this this is where it
gets really trippy
uh for me because from susquehanna
and friends we had lenny saskind as a
podcast guest some time ago
um i i'm i'm given to believe that i can
think of the black hole in the
traditional way as
a region of space-time and if i go
inside i can't go out
and nothing special happens when i enter
inside except that i'm doomed to
eventually hit the
singularity but i can also if i'm
outside
think of everything inside the black
hole as just living on its horizon
living on the
boundary and so there's two different
ways of talking that sound very
different but are equivalent
is that is that fair the way i put it
yeah that's a completely fair way to put
it and it's one of the things that's
very beautiful about working with
quantum gravity is that you have these
two different descriptions
of the same system and they look
completely different and
they are telling you different things
that at the end of the day have to be
one and the same
apart many of the insights that we have
obtained about
gravitational physics and quantum
gravity in the past few years
in the past more than a decade a couple
decades
it's they've been a result of this
duality we call it
between two different descriptions that
are really the same yeah i think and
we'll this leads us right into ads cft
which is perfect but but first i want to
sort of pause and sort of savor this for
a bit because
it seems to me to be a huge implication
that in some sense space time is
overrated
right like uh einstein really
the reason why spooky action had
distance bugged him so much is because
he thought that without space time you
can't even sensibly talk about physics
and of course we have space
time but we're saying that one single
physical situation could have two
very different space-timey kinds of
descriptions depending on how you want
to look at it so it can't be the space
time itself that is central or
fundamental
absolutely yeah the space-time is not
fundamental and in fact there are
there are different ways of seeing this
but uh we
we certainly think that if you uh zoom
in enough space time itself breaks down
it's only an approximation it's an
approximate notion
that uh that we see when we're looking
at it from far away
so to give an an analogy if you are
uh listening to this and you're sitting
at at your desk maybe it's made of wood
maybe it's made of something else
it looks pretty solid right but if
you're if you zoom in
what you end up saying is molecules and
it's the same basic idea that space time
is uh it looks well i guess maybe it's
difficult to say what spacetime looks
like maybe you've seen those fabric
diagrams but
general idea time appears to be pretty
continuous space appears to be
continuous to us
but if you zoom in enough well the
expectation is that
it breaks down into some more
fundamental constituents
and i think just to i think it's even
worse than that unless i'm
misunderstanding because
um i think when you say something like
that people will think
it's less radical than it is the idea
like i could
have some fundamental discreteness or
you know there's the plank length and
that's the
shortest distance and really it's kind
of like a lattice or a set of molecules
or something but this
holography stuff says that you know no
space-time is just kind of like a
a way of thinking an impression a way of
talking about something that
doesn't even have locations in space if
you're if you come right down to it it's
a convenient description
that's all it is and there might be more
than one for the same physical situation
that's right that's exactly right it is
you're right it is it is more radical
it's easier to think about the
discretization of space time on small
scales but just because it's easier
doesn't really get to get away with it
and and good so we've been uh teasing it
a little bit but
probably the most uh dramatic
manifestation of this or at least the
one we understand
the best and therefore can appreciate
its dramatic consequences
is this weird thing called the ads tft
corresponding yes
um so i i assume you want me to to
discuss it now
i think maybe yeah
no because i i not even though you know
i could try to explain it but i think
that uh
number one you probably understand it
better but also like hearing different
people's explanation of it i think
is always very very useful yeah so the
ada cft correspondence is an incredibly
precise uh
in manifestation as you said of this uh
this dual nature
of quantum gravity that it emits
multiple descriptions
all of which are really describing the
same fundamental system
so what is the what is the laboratory
here so the laboratory
is you can imagine quantum gravity in
some sense sitting in a box so we've put
quantum gravity in a box this is a place
where we can uh
we can maybe have a better conceptual
understanding of it this
uh the reason this duality is called ads
cft is that we call the box
ads so we have this quantum gravity
theory in a box
maybe the box is uh let's say it has
three three spatial dimensions and
we like to say one time dimension so
four dimensions total
in this box um and we we can think of
they're all these physical processes
maybe there are black holes forming
inside the box
they're evaporating and all of this can
be described in the language of quantum
gravity inside the box and
we don't have the greatest control over
that language except in certain cases
where maybe it looks a lot like
classical gravity but it also admits a
completely
different description in terms of a
theory that lives
in one fewer dimensions and has no
gravity at all
it's just a quantum field theory that
instead of living
in four dimensions like the box it lives
in three dimensions two
spatial dimensions in one time dimension
and there is a dictionary
that relates processes and objects in
this quantum field theory
to processes and constructs in the
quantum gravity theory
even though this quantum field theory
does not
actually contain gravity which is to say
this is a quantum field theory that does
not interact with gravity
we can you can think of it if you like
as living on on just
flat space which is never curved and has
nothing to do
with uh with any of these black hole
formation or evaporation
this is an incredibly powerful tool
because it tells us
that for example if in this quantum
field theory
information is not lost then it is also
not lost in the quantum gravity
no matter how much we may not understand
how to fix hawking's calculation
it nevertheless gives us the conclusive
answer that information is not lost
in quantum gravity if it is not lost in
this quantum field
small businesses have unique needs and
despite the current uncertainty
one thing that remains unchanged is the
importance of having the right people on
your
team when your business is ready to make
that next hire
linkedin jobs can help by matching your
role with qualified candidates so that
you can find the right person
quickly you know that everybody is on
linkedin or if not strictly speaking
everybody
linkedin is an active community of
professionals with more than
690 million members worldwide
and when you place a job ad linkedin
jobs will screen for candidates who have
exactly the hard
and soft skills you're looking for then
put that ad
in front of qualified members every day
so that it's seen by people looking
for the job that you're advertising when
your business is ready to make that next
hire find the right person with linkedin
jobs
you can pay what you want and get the
first fifty dollars off
just visit linkedin.com slash mindscape
again that's linkedin.com slash
mindscape
to get fifty dollars off your first job
post terms and conditions apply
and uh it it's it's amazing because it's
sort of
the most in your face version of this
space-time is not fundamental
story right you know you could say well
okay a black hole
i could think of as the interior or just
the boundary but you know black holes
are weird and extreme and
here's an example where the whole theory
can be thought of as
quantum gravity in three plus one
dimensions or
quantum field theory without gravity at
all in two plus one dimensions and
you're telling me
they're secretly the same theory
completely that's right did the whole
dimension where did it go there's a
whole gravitational
theory you know they stand curvature
where did it go somehow
it's all encoded in this quantum field
theory it's i think it's it's remarkable
it's
uh i i've been working on it i would say
my entire career
and i uh i still find it remarkable yeah
and i mean so let's just get some of the
naive questions out of the way aren't
there more
points in a four-dimensional space time
than in a three-dimensional space time
how is there enough information in a
three-dimensional space time to
reconstruct a whole four-dimensional
space-time there is
clearly not enough information in
three-dimensional space-time
but that doesn't mean that there isn't
enough information in the
three-dimensional
theory of quantum fields so there is
something about the quantum fields
you could imagine in certain naive
situations you could think of it as the
energy scale
of the system that can result in this
that
actually describes this additional
direction this additional dimension
which is missing in this quantum field
theory so it's not that the space time
contains the information the
three-dimensional space time
doesn't contain the information about
the four-dimensional space time
it's the quantum field theory that lives
in this three-dimensional space-time
that contains the missing or
quote-unquote missing information
very very roughly it's almost as if the
energy of what's going on in the quantum
field theory acts like an extra
dimension or from that
arises the extra dimension yeah yeah
exactly in certain cases you can
actually make this very exact and
precise and so this is going to be
another pet peeve of mine it's not pet
peeve but like a long-standing issue
that i'm just always very puzzled about
the counting of degrees of freedom
degrees of freedom being how we you know
just say well whatever the quantum stuff
of which things are made we don't know
what it is
we'll call them degrees of freedom um in
quantum field theory
in any box i can put an infinite number
of degrees of freedom there can be an
infinite number of
things that could happen inside that
bond um
and therefore the entropy of that box
could be
the entanglement entropy could be
infinitely big i guess we didn't say out
loud but
in because there is entanglement things
inside a box can be entangled with
outside
things outside and that contributes to
the entropy right because you don't know
what
what's going on outside um but a black
hole
which is supposed to be the most we can
fit in a region
only has a finite entropy and that that
suggests to me
maybe to you that there's only a finite
number of things that can happen in a
region of space where black holes are
possible where you can have gravity
where you're not an ordinary quantum
field theory and that's a dramatic
departure
from the usual way we think about
quantum field theory as a quantum theory
yes absolutely and part of it is this is
is the fact that
we don't have a continuum in gravity so
there's a limit to how much you can
squeeze how many points
you can squeeze into a space if each
point has to have some fundamental
length of fundamental volume to it
there's a limit to how much you can
actually put in space
so you can think of this as being partly
a result of the fact that quantum
gravity
does not permit you to have a continuum
of space
and that always helped me maybe it was
just an emotional help rather than a
technical uh physics theory help but
it helped me reconcile ads with cft
because
cfd which stands for conformal field
theory on the boundary
doesn't have gravity and therefore every
little bit
of that space time can have an infinite
number of things going on
and the ads which stands for
anti-decider space is the theory with
gravity
it's infinitely big and it has an extra
dimension
but it also has gravity so you can sort
of fit less into each region
yes definitely there are also various
ways of
i suppose you could say in certain cases
the infinity is math
and so there is a sense in which things
are infinite in the same way
but the entropy of a black hole is not
one of those infinite things it is
actually finite
well i guess this brings up a very
important question because i do i'm sure
there are some string theory skeptics
out there
um adscft came about from the minds of
string theorists
it does it does it rely on string theory
the conjecture or is it just compatible
with it
uh so in its very initial
formulations in the initial incarnation
it was derived
well derived is perhaps a very strong
word but it was it was shown
as a consequence of certain types of
string theory constructions
now um today we have seen so much
strong evidence in favor of ads cft that
we take it to be a conjecture that's in
some sense independent
of string theory although certainly they
are compatible with one another
right and a lot of aspects of ads cft
take inspiration from string theory
but i i would not say that ads cfd
relies on string theory
and okay again another little diversion
but again this is the the fun thing
about podcasts is that they're not
formal lectures so we can be a little
bit more
uh let our hair down uh do you think of
yourself as a string theorist
that's a really hard one um
you know this this past year in the
annual strengths conference uh
strings 2020 and the year before that
there's always someone who asks what is
string theory
what do we include under the banner
string theory if you go to one of these
conferences
these annual gatherings of the of many
many of us in the community and people
go to these
you'll see everyone from people who work
on more formal aspects of quantum field
theory
to people who work on general relativity
and and also people who work on very
formal mathematical aspects of string
theory
and so i i think that while you could
define a string theorist as someone who
literally computes
the scattering amplitudes of strings
yeah or someone who works on formal
model building constructions or
f theory you could also be more liberal
with your definition of a string
theorist
and say it is anyone who works on
quantum gravity
inspired by the perspective that comes
from string theory
and if you go by that definition then i
would
class myself as a string theorist right
i mean it's funny because i i
have had several string theorists on the
podcast i always ask them a question no
one has ever said
yes i'm a string theorist there's always
like well it depends what you mean but
you know
i think that's important because it
helps people who are not embedded as
experts in the field to appreciate that
the labels are not really what matters
right we're all
doing whatever we can at the moment to
try to figure things out
exactly we use whatever tools we happen
to think are the most
likely to help us move forward good and
so
you mentioned a little bit how we should
give credit to here to juan maldasena
who was the first person to suggest
ads cfd correspondence and how it came
from string theory but it's sort of
it has a life of its own now you know
it's grown up and left the house
would how would you um put the question
of how sure we are that ads c of t
is right um it's not something it's hard
to prove right because we know what a
conformal field theory is but we're not
completely sure what quantum gravity
in anti-descender space is so showing
that they're exactly the same is a bit
tricky if you'd only know what one of
them
is right uh so the correspondence has
passed a number of highly non-trivial
checks and in cases where we can't
calculate things on both sides of the
duality
they do agree so in the limit where
quantum gravity
looks like general relativity yeah we
can do calculations
in the in the gravitational theory and
if those if that happens to be a limit
where we can
also compute certain things in the
conformal field theory then we can
compare the two
and and we get agreement and so it this
uh this
the correspondence it has passed a
number of very non-trivial tests and
checks
we have not proven it and we do need to
be careful about that
but there is in in my mind there is uh
i feel fairly confident that ads cft
modulo may be a few small caveats and
modifications but by and large
that the the correspondence is genuine
right
i mean is it is it a plausible
perspective
that there's something called conformal
field theories and those are perfectly
well defined they're some of the best
defined quantum field theories we have
and in some cases we're very very
confident
that you can think of what's happening
in such a theory as
quantum gravity and anti-dissider space
and so like it's not
a balance between two equally rigorously
defined theories but it's one theory
with two different ways of looking at it
certainly that is one that's one
perspective that we can take
i i do i am a proponent of the idea that
quantum gravity admits an independent
description of quantum
conformal field theory okay and that if
we are able to actually
find that description then we will be
able to have an independent check
there are some people who are simply
saying quantum gravity should simply be
in an anti-disorder space
should simply be defined right as this
conformal field theory
and i think that i i'm not ready
to uh to jump on that just yet okay i
think that we we should be
still be looking for an independent
description of quantum gravity
that comes about perhaps more naturally
in variables that
in variables that more naturally give
rise to general relativity in the
appropriate limit
good all right good so those are my
worries out of the way and we can get
back onto the main track of our progress
here
you mentioned that one of the nice
things about ads cft
is that on the conformal field theory
side it's
just obvious that information is
conserved right that's something we're
perfectly confident about
yes is there a simple way of saying why
we're confident about that uh
well we can literally look at
the state of this uh conformal field
theory we can look at it very far in the
past
and we can just evolve it forwards using
the
the way that we know things are evolved
in this conformal field theory
and at no point is information ever lost
the entropy
you could say never changes it's always
the same good
and so information is not lost and and
therefore people take this as evidence
that if
whatever happening in the conformal
field theory is equivalent to something
happening
in ads when that something is a black
hole then we believe that information
shouldn't be lost when the black hole
evaporates either
precisely yeah so if if this conformal
field theory
is able to describe an evaporating black
hole
then it is clear that information is not
lost good
and okay so that but but that's sort of
good to know
and confirm something we wanted to be
true but is a little bit less than
sort of actionable like so it's it's
telling us that the information
does get out when the black hole
evaporates at least
in ads we can talk about whether or not
that's true in wider circumstances
but it doesn't really tell us how is
that fair that's right yeah it's not
this is not a time for singing pains
just yet
we are not ready to do that uh just
knowing that the information is
conserved
it's not quite enough so we could just
as easily have all sat down in some
secret cabal meeting and decided we all
say information is conserved
so be it but um in order to have a
resolution to this problem
we need to actually say how yes how it
happens
what is the process by which it happens
we need to do a calculation
that actually shows at least indicates
that information is conserved in an
incontrovertible way
in terms of the quantities of the
problem for example in terms of the
entropy of the radiation in terms of
that doing a calculation that shows that
the entropy
obeys the information conservation that
it starts out at some value and it ends
up at that value
that is the the hallmark of information
conservation and
in order to make progress this is not
it's not the end point yet because we
want to
just understand things more broadly but
in order to even start making progress
that's something that we need right or i
should say something that we
needed to do for a long time and have
recently made some progress on anyway
yeah so
i will i will i will delay just to build
the dramatic tension
and uh because i need i need to convey a
personal story here because
this idea that adscft shows that well
it should be information conserving all
along uh
even stephen hawking was pretty moved by
that right he changed his mind for a
long time he said
information is lost and basically
because of ads cft he changed his mind
and he gave a famous talk about it i
think around the year
2004 or five and uh it was
at a time that was primitive enough in
the internet that the talk was not
broadcast
or recorded or nor was there even a uh
text of what he said available anywhere
and the new york times wrote about it
and i i asked
dennis overby at the new york times like
have you actually seen stephen hawking's
talk the text of it uh and he said yeah
i'll send you a copy of it
they gave out a copy and so i asked
permission and i
posted the the text of the talk on my
blog
and this was the only place that was
available for a while so
i helped get the word out there but uh
but
but as you say it still leaves us a
little bit stuck as to what is actually
going on so
so now i'm in a realm where you're way
ahead of me and i'm gonna have to rely
on you to to help us out
why or what what is it that has given us
new um confidence or hope that we
actually have an idea
how the information is getting out not
just that it is
uh so we did a calculation and i say
when i say we i should name
the people so this was a this was a set
of two papers that came out the same day
one by jeff pennington and one by
madonna harry
myself henry maxfield and don merrill
and we
did a calculation in the quantum gravity
theory in the box
that i will explain in a minute that
in fact showed we calculated the entropy
and this calculation showed that the
entropy
actually behaves in a way that is
consistent
with information conservation so this is
the entropy
black hole that you're calculating or
the entropy of what yeah good
so we calculated the entropy so
there are two steps to this first we
wanted to take a black hole that
evaporates
and um and this is what's challenging in
its own right because black holes in ads
well they don't really like to evaporate
very much
and if they do evaporate then they're
they're kind of difficult to describe so
first we had to go through
a number of steps in order to just uh
get these things to agree to evaporate
um but but but once we did we actually
were able to have uh analytical control
retractable
situation where we could use a
particular proposed formula
to compute the entropy of the
of the black hole and or you could say
the entropy of the radiation
by a slightly different formula okay
that
uh as a function of time and so
what we found which was extremely
non-trivial
we found that the entropy of the black
hole or
the entropy of the radiation actually
behaves in a way that has been
shown by by don page to be the way in
which it must behave if the
evolution conserves information if the
evolution of the black hole evaporation
process
conserves information so this was uh
this was a
an explicit calculation done in quantum
gravity language
that uh that actually indicates very
strongly
here is information conservation and by
when a physicist says something like
extremely non-trivial
you you mean basically like it could
have gone otherwise you didn't sort of
cook the books by putting it in there
like you know when you start the
calculation you're not sure where it's
going to go
and it ended up exactly where you hoped
yeah it was
uh you know we were actually this was
not the thing that we necessarily set
out to calculate
um we set out to uh well we set out to
to show
that a certain um certain quantum
information theoretical protocol has in
particular geometric realization
uh and and this the fact that we got
this this behavior
was uh was extremely exciting and and it
was
oh yeah it was not something that we put
in by hand at all
okay so you have good so you have the
black hole and it has
an entropy and you have the radiation it
has an entropy
and maybe this is going to be ambitious
but what do you mean
by saying it evolves in the way you
expected it to is it like the entry gets
transferred from the black hole to the
radiation as it as it evolves
um you could think of it that way but
it's uh it's better to think of it like
this
um let's just think about the radiation
for a second
um so the the radiation when the black
hole
is young when it's first formed um the
the radiation is is
basically we could say oh it just formed
it only just started evaporating so
uh we basically know everything there is
to know uh about the the black hole
everything there is to know about
everything
there's to know about the radiation so
so its entropy is is very small
and then as the black hole evaporates
some things fall into the black hole
some of the radiation makes it out um
the entropy grows because our ignorance
grows
but if the black hole if once the black
hole evaporates completely
the uh the all the information got out
then the entropy should go back to zero
after the black hole finished
evaporating because the ignorance
is not existing because we know
everything about the system and
this this type of behavior where the
entropy first increases and then
decreases
is uh is something called the attributed
to don page is something called the page
curve
which is uh which is what we think of as
a litmus test for information
conservation and so when we when i say
we calculated things and they behaved in
this way i literally mean we computed
the entropy using a a formula that that
aaron wall and i proposed in 2014
and and this exactly produced this type
of behavior where it starts out
at zero and it ends up at zero and so
if we didn't have i mean what what could
have gone wrong what how what is it that
makes it non-trivial what other kind of
curve could you have gotten if things
were not working out
right so if you if you were to do the
calculation that hawking did
yes then what you would get is that the
entropy would start increasing
and then and then if the black hole
finished evaporating
well the entropy would still be high
because you lost information so you
still have ignorance about about the
about the system even though you have
access to the whole universe information
was lost so there is some ignorance
and so the entropy would have just
continued to increase until the black
hole evaporated and there would have
just remained a const
but because what we saw instead is that
that it did not do that it did not
follow what we call the hawking behavior
but it followed the page behavior that
is
evidence of information conservation
okay but if i'm
if i'm still being the devil's advocate
here i'll say well
but that's still in this ads cft context
where you already convinced yourself
that information was conserved so
how did this extra little uh calculation
help point you in the right direction
good so so i have two things to say
about that first
is that all of the evidence we had in
adscft for information conservation came
from the cft
and this is a calculation that was done
in the gravitational theory so
we used a gravitational prescription for
the entropy
and we computed the entropy using just
what we knew about the quantum gravity
theory
so this was a more direct calculation
which is what we've been looking for
rather than this indirect derivation
now this is this is the first thing i
wanted to say the second is that
uh very exciting developments that
followed that
which have said okay let's uh let's try
to derive
this from not from a different angle
from a different
different type of calculation let's try
to do this calculation uh which is
essentially this formula
that i was quoting that in initial
stages uh aaron wall and i derived it in
2014 and it was then
modified later in 2019 for the but for
the radiation
um let's try to derive that without
assuming adscft
and let's try to justify it and so
these there are two of multiple papers
that followed up but two that really
come to mind
which is by uh a number of folks on the
east coast a number of folks on the west
coast
in our field it goes by the east coast
and west coast papers which is not to
say that we're pitted against one
another
we all work together um but with where
they in in
certain class of models which are
admittedly toy models but we we do
expect that they
are very reflective of other cases they
they actually derive this formula this
calculation
not assuming the adscft correspondence
which means that it is much more robust
than just being special to
ads cft where you can say oh the cft
already told us about this
the fact that we can derive it without
ads cft and we can derive it just with
access to
with access to quantum gravity and not
with access to this alternative language
of the cft
suggests that we are on the right track
to figuring out what is the exact
mechanism that is responsible for the
information getting
out right because calculating the
entropy is
is important it is the stepping stone
but again
the pinnacle the thing that we're
looking for at the end of the day
is this mechanism by which the
information actually gets out
okay so when you say we did some
calculations that do not rely on ads eft
is it even possible to give us a flavor
for how you did that
uh uh would it have worked in flat space
or you know
zero cosmological constant which is
which is not ads or
is it uh you used you imported some
ideas from ads into a different context
do you started anew could stephen
hawking have done this
um so uh so i should say i should issue
a disclaimer that
i was not in on this east coast and west
coast papers
but um i i've been following the
developments as well
and the the basic idea is that
concepts from ads cft were imported
or that the calculations were inspired
by developments in ads cft
in particular by a development that is
attributed it is due to lufkovitz and
maldocena
and it is however not special
to adscft these insights are important
but they're
something we could in general use about
gravity um
there's they're in some sense related to
some older work
about the uh about deriving the entropy
formula
for the for for black holes the
gravitational entropy formula
that was related to the uh the event
horizon and its area right
this it used to construct something
called the gravitational path integral
and uh and in some sense this is a case
of the gravitational path integral
striking again
where this idea this this construct
together with
insights and intuitions and inspiration
from ads cft
together are combined to to give this
derivation
now could hawking have done this well um
it's a question of whether hawking could
have uh could have derived
i would say that it could have given the
love commitment at construction
i suppose that maybe that's a question
that's more for philosophers
yeah okay but you know what i think i
think that if
we should reward uh the listeners who
stuck around for the last hour
and really give them some of the red
meat here let's explain
what a path integral is and what the
gravitational path integral is
um okay would you like to take path
integral while i think of how to
formulate the gravitational path sure
i'll try path integrals um because i
think you know
it's actually even though it's a very
kind of abstract sounding idea it's
probably the kind of thing that
fans of popular level quantum mechanics
have heard of that richard feynman
in his office one day or i don't know in
the strip club or wherever he was
hanging out
uh said you know quantum mechanics
can be thought of as a story of a wave
function
evolving over time but it's there's this
feature
that the more likely thing to happen
is closer to the classical thing that
would have happened right like there's
not a complete disconnect between
quantum mechanics and classical
mechanics so maybe and i have no idea
what actually gave him the idea but he
says
maybe everything happens right i mean
maybe the particle if you think of a
particle moving on a path
uh maybe in quantum mechanics
in classical mechanics there's just a
path the particle
moves on and there's this this idea
called the principle of least action
that
the it it takes the best path the past
that the path that took the least action
to get from one place to another
and feynman says maybe in quantum
mechanics you can think of the particles
taking
every path every wild crazy path zooming
around
you know zipping here and there
completely violating the laws of physics
and then you sort of add up quantum
mechanically the contribution to
from all of those possible paths and
when you're near the classical path
the all the contributions add up and you
get a big answer
and when you're far away from the
classical path you get some
positive contributions and some negative
contributions and they nearly cancel out
so quantum mechanics is sort of taking
advantage of all the different things
you could imagine the system doing and
this is called the path integral because
you have all the different paths and you
integrate over
everything that can happen in them and
you recover it's not like a new theory
you're just recovering standard quantum
mechanics in an imaginative way
thank you that was that was really
beautiful yeah okay
um so the gravitational path integral
is kind of a similar idea but for
gravity and let me let me parse that
statement
so in the ordinary gravitation in the
ordinary path integral as sean just said
we are talking about all possible paths
between two points in uh in a
gravitational theory
we're talking about all possible
geometries
all possible space-time shapes that
have a fixed boundary so for imagine
for example imagine this box we we fix
the boundary of the box we make it rigid
but we allows any any space time you
want
inside of this box any kind of uh funny
shape
black holes anything that that has these
boundaries
that are unchanged and unaltered and we
sum
over all of these possible contributions
without worrying
about whether this space time solves the
uh the equations of einstein's theory of
general relativity or not
but we expect that that when it does we
get these very large contributions
and so we are this is what we would call
a classical
point even though here you could say
we're always talking about something
classical this is the space time
geometry
but here the classical point is the the
geometry the space time
that obeys the einstein equation and
one of the things that are simply
miraculous about the gravitational path
integral
which is different from the path
integral and ordinary cornfield theory
is that it knows a lot more than it has
any right to
we don't know why it knows all of this
but somehow
even though you can look at this
gravitational path integral
and from it you can calculate the
entropy of a black hole
even though this gravitational path
integral you didn't you didn't put in
the underlying fundamental equations of
quantum gravity into it
you didn't tell it what are all of the
possible spaces and
states of quantum gravity it just kind
of knows
it knows what the entropy of a black
hole is it knows the number of
microstates
even though in principle it doesn't
really have a right to
there's no it's not clear why it knows
but it just kind of does
and and it's it's truly a miraculous
this is something that is
this is not new that it knows the
entropy but the
the new aspect to the story is that it
also knows about information
conservation
you can use this gravitational path
integral to compute
the the entropy of the radiation and
if you do that then this gravitational
path integral will tell you
oh the information is conserved it gets
out somehow
how does it know why does it know we
have no idea
and in fact i would i i gave a seminar
recently
and i actually opened with uh with the
question about what is the gravitational
path interval doing
right uh what is it calculating and
how do we find out how do we decode the
gravitational path integral
and this is i think that's so good sorry
i was just going to say i mean this is
this anthropomorphizing of the
gravitational path integral that it
knows more than it should
is a wonderful example of this idea of a
non-trivial
thing going on like uh you know
one thing is that the the gravitational
path integral
what in rather than the path of a
particle we take an entire space time
right so this
a space time is a single path and we're
integrating over all the different space
times but it could have been the case
that you couldn't understand as we as we
suggested early on that understanding
how the information gets out
couldn't be understandable until you had
the final once and for all theory of
quantum gravity
and in some sense the gravitational path
integral isn't
that right it's like it's a it's a you
know
hope and a prayer approximation that we
think might be good in certain
certain you know big universe nice
smooth nothing going on dramatically
circumstances but here it's telling us
more than
we thought it was going to be able to
figure out absolutely
yeah it somehow is able to to to
know the essence of this calculation
even though
the gravitational path integral is
something we can calculate just from the
perspective of uh
what we call semi-classical gravity
gravity with small
quantum contributions where the quantum
effects are not so strong that we lose
control over it
and we can calculate it from that and
that calculation is
telling us that the information is
conserved even though for a very long
time we thought that the only way that
we could
see information conservation was
literally as you say like just having
this big quantum gravity theory and
actually describing it
in full detail in all regimes and
miraculously that's not the case we are
able to make progress just from this
miraculous gravitational path integral i
mean i just find that fascinating yeah
it's miraculous to me it's always fun to
be
to be hearing about these advances in
physics as they're going on because
once they're gone like we always present
them in ways that
just seemed inevitable you know like oh
of course it had to be like this
and but while we're in the middle of
them like holy smokes this is amazing
how does it know absolutely yeah yeah
but there is yeah
it's exactly like that yeah but there is
one thing i think that you know at least
has been suggested
as a bit of insight as to why the path
of a girl knows after all
so the panther rule is saying you know
if you want to say how space time
evolves from one thing
to another you literally take into
account
contributions from every single kind of
space time you can imagine that would
connect
the beginning and the end of the story
you're trying to tell and so presumably
the set of all space times that that
that connect the beginning to the end
would include
the w word we haven't said it yet um
yes
[Laughter]
surprising sorry if i interrupted you
please continue i didn't mean to
interrupt you no
i don't want to be too coy here i'm
thinking about wormholes i i have heard
uh that you know wormholes play a
crucial role
in getting the information out in the
context of this story and
once you say that word you know people
people have probably seen the little
picture of a wormhole right you know
they know the general idea but
they're gonna think that somehow you you
want to tell me that
i throw the book into the black hole and
it escapes outside by a wormhole but i'm
sure it's not as easy as all that
yeah so um so i think what's the best
way to
uh to explain this so so just to address
an earlier point that you made um the
so i would say what's miraculous about
the gravitational path integral is
even in this approximation where we
think of it as uh
as roughly in terms of the space-time
geometry that satisfies the einstein
equation where we approximate it
as something that looks like that we can
still get the information that we need
and that that so we don't actually need
to have access to all of those metrics
all of those
geometries that don't actually solve the
einstein equation now
regarding to regarding what as to how
the the information gets out and how
that's related to these wormholes
um so it's these wormholes the way that
they
uh that they contribute is in the
calculation of the
entropy rather than as a description
of the space time on which the
information is propagating
so the obviously hawking radiation is
propagating
so i would be hesitant to say that
we have a that these wormholes are
giving us the mechanism
via which information gets out now i say
hesitant
because i don't want to strike too
strong a position on this
simply because i know there will be
others who will disagree with me
and also we don't want to present a fair
view yeah
we're not done yet i want a fair view of
the field here so even though
i think in my opinion that we that we
have not
uncovered the mechanism and we have not
answered the question
of uh how the information actually
escaped i am sure that there are some
people who have
ideas about the wormholes and how they
are related to the mechanism by which
information gets out
so i want to give credit to those people
even though i do not necessarily agree
with that perspective
well i think you know people are uh
exposed to various ideas
in in the popular media so it's
important to sort of relate
our ideas to each other uh lenny suskin
and juan maldasena famously suggested
that
whenever two particles are entangled
just like in ordinary quantum field
theory
we can think of them as being connected
by a microscopic quantum wormhole
er equals epr is this kind of like that
or related or completely different
or two sides of the same coin it's it's
not like that so the
uh so lenny and juan's wormholes are
what we call
um spatial normals so they
this wormhole is a wormhole in space if
you look at a single
moment in time then you would see this
uh this warm hole sort of stereotypical
diagrams connecting two different
universes through a wormhole at any
given moment in time
the wormholes that are discussed in the
context of the gravitational path
integral and the recent calculation
of the entropy of the hawking radiation
are not like that
these are what are called space-time
wormholes
so these are these are wormholes that
are extended
in in time and they
bring up a number of problems for that
reason regarding
um well i maybe i won't go into it
because it's rather technical
but they bring up a number of problems
and the
while lennies and juan's wormholes are
um
werewolves that we can think of as
existing in the space itself in the
space time itself connecting two
particles
these wormholes show up pretty much only
in the calculation of the entropy
yeah so you need to calculate the
entropy to see them rather than in the
space time itself so i was in there two
qualitatively different
phenomena although it is striking that
the wormholes are
appearing here and i i will say that
there are
there are some models where uh one can
talk
about um about both and you could try to
talk about both of these
but i don't think there is a clear
picture a clear indication
that they are related in an obvious way
so i i very much appreciate your attempt
to um
or your desire to not get too technical
uh but i'm going to spoil it
so let me let me say something and you
can tell me whether uh i've completely
missed the boat here which is which is
very possible
um you know when when stephen hawking
and jim hartl
back circa 1980 or i don't know what
what year it was you know they proposed
what they called the wave function of
the universe
and what they said part of their idea
was
what do you mean by a wave function well
you have a wave function
exists at a moment of time right the
wave function
evolves over time in quantum mechanics
so at any one time
you have a wave function and for gravity
that wave function
would presumably say well what is the
geometry of space
at that one moment of time and what are
all the quantum fields doing at the same
moment
and they wanted to calculate that and
they wanted to calculate it by doing
the path integral by doing what feynman
said but
when you actually you know the thing
about the pathing role as beautiful as
the story
is the mathematics of it and the ability
to calculate it
is just god-awful right like nothing is
well-defined nothing is calculable
whatever um yeah and there's this
trick that you can introduce because
what you're supposed to do
is say well integrate up all of the
space times that match on
to this particular wave function you're
looking at but the trick is
instead of integrating all the
four-dimensional space
times that match on to this condition
you're looking at you can just say well
i'm going to integrate over all
four-dimensional spaces
so i'm going to forget about space-time
i'm just going to do what we call the
euclidean
path integral because euclid just talked
about space not time
i went there i did i did this is where
i'm going
and so it was sort of like you could
justify it's a trick it's a mathematical
trick
and it's very rigorously justifiable
in certain simple cases in quantum
mechanics and it certainly has the smell
of being correct
in certain more subtle cases in quantum
field theory in quantum gravity is
what they were doing with it it's just
it just seemed to be a trick so they
could get a finite answer at the end of
the day and it was very unclear
why it had anything to do with the real
world but they suggested it did
maybe they were right and since then i
think we've become a little more
comfortable with the idea that we can
use
this trick of calculating quantum
gravity wave functions by integrating
over
the euclidean path integral the set of
all the spaces
that end up looking like what we want
instead of all the space times that look
like what we want
yes and that's what you that's what
you're doing isn't it that's that's the
kind of wormholes that you're invoking
that's what i was trying to sweep
and you were right to do so but i you
know i just like to live dangerously
here
so lenny and juan have wormholes that
are literally good old in space-time
wormholes and you have wormholes that
are in
these fake euclidean spaces that you use
to calculate the entropy
that's exactly right yeah that's exactly
right and these fake euclidean space
stands
have more boundaries there are more
edges than our original space-time
which means that these wormholes are
connecting these uh
these more edges than we have in our
original time and therefore
it's difficult to make sense of them in
terms of the original
space time that we started with right
okay so
what's next where are we going from here
what are
i mean you're very very kind i should i
should make sure that everyone in
the audience knows how uh very very
thoughtful it is of you to appear
on this podcast because i know that like
in theoretical physics
like you said there are fallow periods
where like we're wondering what to do
and then there's like periods of amazing
excitement
where you just want to get working and
so you're taking off time of your real
work to be on here but
uh what are you gonna turn to next once
we're done chatting here
uh well like i said before i think that
the
the gravitational path integral is is
something that we need to really think
about why does it know
what it knows and how does it calculate
it at the end of the day
we would like to give a complete
description
of how the information gets out if
you're an observer
who's sitting outside the black hole and
you have a bunch of beam splitters and
mirrors
and you're measuring the radiation what
do you see
how do you see information conservation
how does that happen
and we need to be we want to be able to
describe those so we can actually
put a rest to the information paradox of
course not for its own sake
but because having a paradox in quantum
gravity is telling us that
there's something we're thinking about
wrong so this is going to tell us a lot
more about quantum gravity
and i think that we now have a quantity
that we know knows the answer and it's
up to us to
in some sense ask the path integral the
right question in order to figure out
what the answer is so we have
ascertained the path interval knows the
answer it knows how to give us the right
answer every time
and we need to ask ourselves why what is
it
actually calculating what is this thing
that it is doing behind the scenes
that is giving the right answer how do
we compute that without using the
gravitational path integral
how do we see it directly in from the
physics of quantum gravity
these are all questions that that i
think we have to answer
if we want to get to the bottom of the
information paradox and at the end of
the day
one could take the attitude that the
information paradox is
a motivation but it's not the goal in
some sense right the goal is to
understand much bigger questions and
this is just the sort of puzzle that
we've been gnawing over for some decades
now
trying to get there do you think there
could be implications of this
uh set of things we've discovered for
things
like the wave function of the universe
or the big bang or whatever
um i do so i think one of the most
exciting things about the recent
discoveries
is that they've sort of lift up to our
expectation that understanding the black
hole information paradox better
is going to teach us a lot more about
gravity and quantum gravity right so
the reason that we care about paradoxes
in the first place is because they're
telling us that there's something we're
thinking about wrong
in terms of quantum gravity there's some
somewhere we messed up and
the hope is that in resolving them will
understand that better of course it's an
it's an abstract hope
but i think it's fair to say that it's
starting to be realized so for example
the inclusion of these wormholes these
uh
normal these euclidean wormholes in the
euclidean path integral
is uh it is mysterious from many many in
many ways
because it suggests that there is some
very strange mechanism that uh
that describes gravity in uh in a full
quantum gravity theory so there is
there's been some suggestion for
one way of thinking about it is there's
a possibility that
really gravity is described by a
collection of quantum theories what we
call an ensemble
rather than a single theory there have
been suggestions of some kind of uh
that there is some kind of an averaging
that is happening in order to obtain
gravity from these theories
and all of these different hypotheses
that are currently under development
some papers have come out some people
are working on them i'm working on this
um all of this is a consequence of
the understanding that these these
euclidean wormholes
have to contribute and they that they
give rise to
information conservation and those
insights are telling us something
fundamental
about quantum gravity regardless of
whether we care about the black hole
information paradox or not and so there
is a clear sense in which the black hole
information paradox is living
up to what we had hoped which is that if
we gain true insight into it then it
will lead us on the path to
understanding quantum gravity better
that is exciting i'm excited i think
this is great i think this is great
i'm really excited too yeah good good
good this is this is the fun part of
what we do for a living so
uh with that in mind i can't think of a
better place to end netangleheart thanks
so much for being on the winescape
podcast
it was my pleasure thank you for having
me
[Music]
you